I'm taking a couple of weeks off and
while I'm gone some brilliant people are
standing in for me here versus Alex from
brain book he's a brain surgeon
there's nothing gruesome in this video
but there is the answer to a question I
never knew I had
how did neurosurgeons find their way
around inside the brain neurosurgery is
fraught with risk the brain is packed
with almost a hundred billion neurons
compartmentalized into complex bundles
of nerves and other structures that make
you who you are small parts of your
brain are vital for allowing you to
speak move think learn and love as
neurosurgeons we operate in and around
these vital structures and spend a great
deal of time learning the anatomy so
that we can operate safely the room for
error can be millimeters as we maneuver
around blood vessels and critical nerves
and damaging any of these can cause
either life-changing or life ending
complications no matter how good the
surgeon and no matter how good their
knowledge we can still go astray and
need a helping hand neurosurgery is a
specialty that's inherently intertwined
with cutting-edge technology and we can
use that to guide us when we're
navigating the brain today I'm going to
show you how neurosurgeons can use
infrared and electromagnetic image
guidance systems to show us exactly
where we are in the brain during
critical operations like brain tumor
surgery or inserting biopsy needles deep
into the brain this is a Medtronic
stealth station s8 it's a combination of
hardware and software they use a special
trackable instruments such as this
pointer and distillate to be able to
guide the neurosurgeon the system tracks
the position of these instruments in
relation to the surgical Anatomy and
sends that information to the software
the software then displays the
instruments position on either the CT or
MRI scan of that patient the system can
track instruments either optically using
an infrared camera or
electromagnetically with optical
tracking this camera sends out and then
detects infrared lights that's reflected
from these silver balls the camera then
transmits the instruments location to
the navigation software
similarly with electromagnetic tracking
the emitter emits a low-energy magnetic
field with unique characteristics at
every point the electromagnetic
instruments contain sensors which allow
the navigation software to identify the
instruments location within the
electromagnetic field for the software
to display the instruments location in
relation to images of the patient you've
got to help the software by creating a
map between points on the patient and
points in the images this process is
called registration and it's essentially
the same for both optical and
electromagnetic types after registration
is complete whenever the surgeon touches
a point on the patient using one of
these tracked instruments the computer
uses the map to identify the
corresponding point on the images this
identification is called navigation and
now I'm going to show you both systems
in action here we've got an MRI scan of
a brain model but we're going to use
coming up you see this white blob which
is supposed to be a simulated brain
tumor on the MRI scan up here you can
see an eye coming into view and then the
nose so this is the brain that's going
to correspond with the model in the
bottom right hand corner wheezing
infrared tools and you can see the
pointer coming into reference with the
reference array that we've got fixed to
the patient's head we're going to be
doing registration as we mentioned
before marking out lots of points with
the infrared pointer now we can verify
the registration we've got one point
five millimeter accuracy which we'll do
for this simulation so we're going to
touch the tip of the nose on the model
and you can see in the MRI that that
correlates well let's look at the inner
part of the eye and that looks good the
outer part of the eye and the tip of the
ear and this is all looking like its
corresponding really nicely if we put
the pointer into this hole that's
pre-made where on the tumor so that's
looking good as well and this is a
premade craniotomy or trapdoor in the
skull that's gonna allow us to just
access the tumor straight away
in real life we'd make this whole and I
would take about 45 minutes to an hour
having cut through the skin and drilled
off this bone so we can operate around
this tumor and see exactly where we are
on the brain avoiding critical
structures like blood vessels nerves and
parts of the brain that are important
for speaking and seeing for example now
let's move on to the electromagnetic
form of navigation which is also called
axiom guidance we're going to be using a
rowena neurosurgical simulator and
thanks a lot to Suzy Glover from Delta
and Stephanie Brown from NHS healthcare
horizons this model is quite cool
because it actually has fluid systems
within it and here you can see us
actually scanning it and we're gonna
take these CT images and plug them into
the software and here you can see we've
put the model in pins but we don't
usually do that because it can interfere
with the electromagnetic system we're
going to be using this sterlet to guide
a piece of tubing deep into the brains
fluid reservoirs this pointer is what
we're going to use to do a registration
this is the actual catheter that we're
going to be inserting deep into the
brain and we'll take out the little
metal select that comes with it and
insert the tracked axiom Salette that
comes with the electromagnetic system so
now that catheter is tracked we can use
this pointer to mark out exactly what
trajectory we're going to be using and
see where we're going to need to make a
cut and then later on where we're going
to make a burr hole which is a small
hole in the skull that allows us to
access the brain now we're going to mark
it with a red marker in this case and
start drilling
[Music]
once we've made the hole and done a bit
more work in real life we're ready to
put the catheter in on the right you can
see that the stealth station is showing
us how far we need to go and shows us a
target that we've pre planned we're
going to follow that trajectory and make
sure the green dots line up as we
advance the catheter down it gives us a
countdown in millimeters once we reach
zero we should be in the ventricle
system and as I take out the metal
sterlet from inside the tubing fluid
should start coming out and there we are
we are in and in real life we've now
secured this catheter and get out of
there don't subscribe to drain books
start with this video on a day in the
life of a neurosurgeon on call next week
we go from brain surgery to settling on
Mars
you